welcome to this video hematite this is
right Brown okay what do we get a Kings
Indian defense yeah playing the
classical variation going 492 what i
recently tried out a bit with pretty
good results i think the results were
okay the positions were even better we
just kind of kind of typical for the
Kings in yet you tend to quite off news
good positions because it's such a
tricky opening okay I think would be one
in before is the way to go yeah do you
actually play a three year or not I
don't remember well maybe yeah night f4
okay but I have to place if I hear no no
use in pretending to think you just have
to do this kind of thing and then see
what happens the Knight to f4 is quite
often tricky to to play against so
aggressively plays fees but one thing is
clear like orphans on the queenside is
also progressing rather quickly our
vision mission / to f6 really it looks
that it's a very slow plan ok I'm going
to start with that and then plate we
should be three so that I have Bishop b6
really on Bishop g5 not sure a strong it
is but it is it is something that has to
worry about
96 is also an idea
that really should be good for idea how
does he how does he defend us his
weaknesses there's also night be five
which is getting more interesting now
night b5 attacking d6 he only has rook a
six to defend and Bishop be Bishop here
what is he doing then coming 27 maybe
Queen D cell I wanted to go Bishop f2
just improving a little bit and to
threaten Knight b6 it's a very awkward
very awkward and please please PLEASE
placement so still night b5 looks good
night be 500 k 6 7 just about holding or
i can take everything I cannot I
probably cannot hmm I'd be success of
course also not bad but not be five rook
a six I cannot go look a one
unfortunately okay come on playing with
him this is this is a case where many
moves are good so I should play one of
them not sure if this was the best 196
though but okay
it's kind of shaky does this thing like
there might be some kind of weird tactic
it's always with the night on a forum
where you have to worry okay might be
five right k this active defense looks
into yup I'm not blundering stuff him
yeah I deal here I deal in this position
would be to trade the bishop okay what
is he doing stick let's take first ask
questions later yeah trading this bishop
on c8 and then get a night somewhere to
eat six or so it would be fantastic also
trading there and then Bishop g4 is also
a Muslim Oh what okay so i see but if i
take it yes b6 is hanging and g3 last
night age three
I can go to you three I really can do
that we should be five or what
keep taking is not bad actually we will
just take care i already have our time
to assess that it's not easy take F to
hoop cakes okay
surprising you now know I think I'm
finally getting rid of this bloody night
it really it really annoys this night on
f4 check have to check not a problem at
all ok and if I I don't know if I go
especially for move no Queen Queen B 6
something that I have to be aware of
Quincy's princes having not shown ok
come chatter playable
check-check
okay it's really not much like that I
can do here check check triumph or try
for nine more 92 chick
yeah that's kind of strange I know
bishop CA is my idea okay draw power
check game draw yep it's just a draw
yeah okay sport a good position here
definitely but yeah may my experience
some I mean I'm lacking experience in
those positions and probably someone
more knowledgeable would play play this
quicker this this must be really good
for idea my queen side players progress
very nicely and 94 was very very
promising actually I saw the idea before
but not not at this particular moment
now black only has one movie that is not
completely losing right away and this is
something that you don't really find
easily this is this is in fact I mean
it's winning for white but it's it's
it's kind of kind of tricky at least the
Queen comes up now g3 seems to win
according to stock fish but this is
scary so the somewhat scary proposition
to play that and ki took their which is
switches of course very meek in
comparison chat here check but this
still should be good right okay note C
seven wins can i play this lame move
yeah I'm really out of shape at the
moment
9726 I mean how obvious do you want it
he has his here ego solely has no way to
keep his pieces together even you will
loose material him it's just like that
the night will come here this is this is
it cannot survive that 98 even yeah to
move the King maybe or something and
that's a disaster I'm taking it yeah
it's plus form it's plus 4 yeah skipping
skipping many gives away many many
opportunities yeah yeah this this is
just nothing that's just nothing we
should be 4i is in fact interesting move
but I just miss everything check check
yeah this is just a draw cannot do much
[ __ ] okay thanks for watching